♪♪♪
>> THIS TUESDAY NOVEMBER 5th
DEMOCRATS ARE BRINGING
MUCH-NEEDED CHANGE TO AMERICA.
THERE'S A BLUE WAVE ON THE
HORIZON AND I HAVE NEVER FELT
MORE CONFIDENT.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE TAKING BACK THE
HOUSE.
IT'S A WIN WE NEED AND A WIN
WE'RE GOING TO GET.
I'M SURE OF IT.
>> THEY SAY DON'T TRUST THE
POLLS, BUT I'M CHOOSING TO.
WE'RE FINALLY GOING TO PUT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IN CHECK.
>> IT'S BEEN A MINUTE, WE'RE
GOING TO WIN.
NANCY PELOSI JUST SAID SO ON
COLBERT.
>> WHITE WOMEN PROMISED TO DO
THE RIGHT THING THIS TIME.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO LET US
DOWN, RIGHT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> WE WIN, YEAH!
>> THIS ONE'S IN THE BAG.
>> I BELIEVE THIS BECAUSE THIS
IS A DEMOCRAT.
>> AND ONCE WE WIN, WILL
EVERYTHING SUDDENLY GET BETTER?
NO, THERE'S STILL A LOT OF LONG,
HARD -- KIDS, GO INSIDE.
MOMMY TOLD YOU, GO INSIDE UNTIL
TUESDAY!
>> UNTIL TUESDAY?
>> JUST GO THE [ BLEEP ] SIGNED!
>> WE CAN'T WAIT TO VOTE.
SO WE WILL AT THE POLLS NEXT
THURSDAY.
>> TUESDAY.
>> I KNOW MOM, I'M KIDDING.
>> IT'S NOT FUNNY!
>> BE PART OF THE VICTORY.
GET OUT THERE AND VOTE.
PROMISE ME YOU'LL VOTE.
>> I AM.
>> IT FEELS PRETTY GOOD!
>> STAY IN THERE!
>> WE'RE GONNA LIVE!
>> WE GOT THIS!
[ APPLAUSE ]